I don't think people should or shouldn't
do anything if they want to make more
money then you optimize for the vehicle
that will make you the most money and
then you do that the whole passion piece
teases out the psychology of humans
because if you're just looking at first
principles of what has to happen build a
business that has the highest leverage
that has the highest total adjustable
Market that has Highest Potential growth
profit per customer and do that that's
what you would need to do if you wanted
to make the most money as soon as you
add in the psychology of humans when you
get tired of this when do you lose
interest in it the big thing for me at
least is that I love business as long as
I'm doing business I'm good and so the
nature of the business doesn't matter I
would say a lot of entrepreneurs are
that way